very
self-assured and know what they want
just like you
Priscilla is speaking out today telling
E.T she loved Elvis and he loved her
Lisa is a result of our love please
ignore the noise referring to an unnamed
individual who quote bought their way
into the family Enterprise this comes as
a source tells E.T Lisa Marie and her
mom did not have a healthy or close
relationship Lisa Marie always felt
Priscilla was trying to have control
over her just eight days ago Elvis's ex
contested Lisa Marie's will claiming the
signature on a 2016 Amendment replacing
Priscilla's trustee with daughter Riley
Keough could have been forged Graceland
when it's no longer mine it would be my
children we're told Riley is
disappointed that her grandmother is
challenging the trust and her mom's
wishes she feels that her actions are
pushing the family apart she does want
to have a relationship with Priscilla
but at this point they are not close
it's expected Lisa Marie may be part of
Sunday's immemorium tribute at the
Grammys where Elvis director baz Lerman
could take home a best compilation
soundtrack award we all became so close
every day I think actually amount the
rest of the family and about how are
they doing you know and yet we have to
march on does it bring you comfort to
know that she is now with her father The
Poetry of that idea is beautiful I want
to believe that that she has come up
[Music]